die absolute sensation zum ersten mal
ist ein interstellare objekt durch unser
sonnensystem gerast zumindest ist es das
erste derartige objekte dass wir
gesichtet haben
und es ist extrem seltsam seine form und
sein verhalten sind absolut rätselhaft
die neuesten erkenntnisse über das
geheimnisvolle interstellare objekt
jetzt endlich zum science fiction
herzlich willkommen
am zweiten september 2017 tauchte das
interstellare objekt senkrecht zu den
umlaufbahnen der planeten in unserem
sonnensystem zwischen sonne und merkur
bahn ein
die gravitation der sondern lenkte das
objekt dann unterhalb der sonne in
richtung erde um wo es unterhalb der
erdumlaufbahn am 14 oktober an der erde
vorbei flog inzwischen ist das objekt
durch die umlenkung der sonne wieder
über die planeten hinaus geschossen
worden
dabei wurde das objekt erst entdeckt als
es schon an der erde vorbeigeflogen war
am 18 oktober 2017 störte das 1,8 meter
teleskop an stars 1 auf der hawaii-insel
maui das objekt auf und dann ergaben die
bahn berechnung des objektes sehr
schnell dass es nicht von dieser welt
war nicht von einem anderen planeten im
sonnensystem und überhaupt nicht aus
unserem sonnensystem es gab noch
überhaupt keine kategorie für das objekt
und weil es irrtümlich für einen
asteroiden gehalten wurde bekam das
erste mal die falsche bezeichnung a 2017
u1 ich hatte ja im ersten video über das
objekt gefragt wie ihr die kategorie
benennen wollt eure vorschläge waren zum
beispiel kino oder fom
jetzt hat die internationale
astronomische union eine neue kategorie
für das interstellare objekt eingeführt
ist jetzt die bezeichnung danke für eure
vorschläge es ist jetzt also 1 2000 17
uhr 1 und hat auch schon einen
hawaiianischen namen bekommen
januar in der hawaiianische sprache
spiegelt dies dieser name die art und
weise wieder in der dieses objekt wie
ein kundschafter unter boote ist der aus
der fernen vergangenheit geschickt wurde
um uns zu erreichen heißt es in einer
studie der universität hawaii die sich
mit diesem ersten interstellaren objekt
beschäftigt und was jetzt absolut
verblüfft auch seine eigenschaften sind
ganz anders als die von asteroiden aus
unserem sonnensystem das interstellare
objekt hat eine extrem seltsame form
eher die eines spiels oder eines
raumschiffes zitat dieses ding ist sehr
merkwürdig das sagt karl match von der
universität hawaii
das team der forscherin hat das objekt
jetzt aufgrund von beobachtungstag näher
beschrieben und es ist wirklich total
merkwürdig mit dem very large telescope
der europäischen südsternwarte eso in
den chilenischen anden
wurde herausgefunden dass das objekt
alle 73 stunden um seine eigene achse
rotiert und dabei immer heller und
wieder dunkler wird um das zehnfache
diese ungewöhnlich starke helligkeits
änderung deutet darauf hin dass das
objekt sehr lang gezogen sein muss etwa
zehnmal so lang wie breit mit einer
komplexen gebundenen form erklärt die
forscherin mit auch extrem seltsam das
objekt hat eine farbe es ist rot das ist
wirklich wirklich alles extrem seltsam
da gastein interstellare objekt durch
unser sonnensystem und es ist so anders
wie alles was wir kennen wenn es nicht
so unglaublich unwahrscheinlich wäre
könnte man es für ein raumschiff halten
so extrem seltsam wie es aussieht hinzu
kommt außerdem konnten wir bestätigen
das ist vollständig inaktiv ist weil wir
in seiner direkten umgebung nicht den
geringsten hinweis auf staub finden
konnten berichtet mieters ist echt
merkwürdig und das forschungsteam
vermutet dass das fremde objekt aus
gestein oder einen mix mit hohen
metallanteil besteht
und anders als zunächst vermutet hat es
nicht einen durchmesser von 160 meter
sondern war sogar 400 meter lang es ist
ein wirklich wirklich seltsames objekt
was meint ihr dass es wahr wenn ihr kein
video zum thema und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann wird
mir hier ein aber aufs auge und
vergessen nicht den auf die glocke der
nur dann verpasst er kein video hier
geht es weiter also hier und da für
einfach draufklicken mit sensation
interstellare objekt rast durchs
sonnensystem mit weiteren infos zur
entdeckung des rätselhaften objekt zu
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran